(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
-Okay. Thank you.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
Thank you. Please.
Oh, what a crowd we got.
But we have such a big show,
there's so much news to get to.
-(INDISTINCT SHOUTING)
-(CHUCKLES) Okay.
MAN: You rock, Bill.
Okay!
-Shut up.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Look, we gotta get to the news,
there's some people
out there watching.
I know we think it's just us,
but...
but-- And here, there's some--
Finally, good news.
Finally, America
is retaliating.
They did this today,
against Russia, for real.
-(WHISTLING)
-Where it hurts,
with the money, with the money.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
-We put sanctions...
We put sanctions on
the biggest Russian oligarchs.
But, you know what?
How come when it's
a rich creep in Russia,
they're an oligarch?
-But when--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
But in America,
you're just a visionary
who founded Facebook?
You know...
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
-(CHEERING)
-Oh, I kid.
Oh, the tech companies--
(SCOFFS)
Did you see what happened
at YouTube this week?
I mean, yes, "Ooh."
A woman who was very disgruntled
about how YouTube
was handling her videos
went in there with a gun,
and fortunately,
nobody was killed,
uh, but it was weird,
and before she started
shooting there, they--
Everybody had to watch an ad.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-I mean--
-(APPLAUSE)
-(BILL CHUCKLES)
Terrible. Terrible.
-MAN: Whoo!
-(WOMAN GIGGLES)
-But no-- (CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
The great news, everybody,
is that Donald Trump, finally,
is unfettered!
You know, he fired, like,
all of his original cabinet,
so he's got
some great new ideas of his own.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Yeah, he's just riffin' now.
Like, this week, troops
at the border. Great!
Yeah, we're putting
National Guard troops
at the border,
even though border arrests
from Mexico
were at their lowest level
since 1971.
Somebody needs to tell him
to have a Mexican stand-off,
you need Mexicans.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
-Uh... (CHUCKLES)
And this-- (CHUCKLES)
This is despite his own people
telling him that using
technology instead of a wall
would be cheaper
and more efficient.
And he said, "If I wanted
cheaper and more efficient,
I'd let the Mexicans in!"
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
-(CHEERING)
-Uh...
But, you know,
people are saying, "Why now?"
"Why now? Why suddenly now,
troops at the border?"
Well, for the same reason
everything happens
in this country now,
because the president
of the United States
saw something on Fox News!
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
They were showing some
fear porn...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-...ab-- (CHUCKLES)
...about-- about a caravan,
did you hear that? A caravan.
(SCREECHES)
It's coming up
from Central America,
migrants through-- Heading north
through Mexico.
That's why now.
Because he watches Fox News
all day.
If he watched
The Price is Right,
we'd be sending troops
to San Francisco
to confront Rice-A-Roni.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
-(CHEERING)
-No--
no wonder the stock market
is going up and down every day,
and tanking and coming back,
and going back down,
because no one knows
what the fuck is happening
anymore.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-We're building a wall,
or maybe not...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-We're having a trade war
with China, or maybe not.
We're getting out of Syria,
or maybe not.
Yeah, the president,
this president,
who has constantly said,
all the time,
"Never tell the enemy
what you're doing,
that's stupid,"
this week, announced
we're pulling out of Syria.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Well, come on.
We're gonna need those troops
for the upcoming invasion
of Amazon.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
You saw this?
He's... (CHUCKLES)
I told you,
he's got a lot of ideas.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Yeah, he's got a big feud with--
Oh, he hates Amazon,
he's mad at Amazon.
He says, "Amazon is using
the Post Office
as a delivery system."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
(BILL CHUCKLES)
The mail is not for Amazon
to use!
The mail is for coupons
I don't want,
and ads for things
I'll never buy
that I throw away
immediately.
That's what the Post Office
is for.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
He-- This guy, he--
-(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
-(BILL CHUCKLES)
He hates China
for making everything we buy.
He hates Amazon for delivering,
and he hates Mexico
for dusting it.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
You know he-- (CHUCKLES)
So he's turned around--
He loved Amazon,
back when they delivered Melania
for two-day free shipping.
(AUDIENCE GASPS AND CHEERS)
(WHISTLING)
No, no, that's-- I'm sorry.
Poor Melania.
-Poor-- Come on. Poor Melania.
-AUDIENCE: Aw!
She has to listen every day
to all the Stormy Daniels news.
Here's what I wanna know.
How come Stormy got paid
$130,000 to shut up,
and Melania's the one
who won't talk?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Talk, Melania!
Speak your truth, girl.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
(CHUCKLES)
Be unfettered like your husband!
He's unfettered now,
he's throwing away the script,
he's turning it up to 11,
he's off the chain,
people are so excited
on the right.
This week-- Did you see this?
Yesterday, it was,
he literally, literally,
threw away the script.
He was in West Virginia,
supposed to be talking
about taxes.
This is what he did. This--
With his prepared remarks.
You know, this was gonna be
my remarks.
That would've taken
about two minutes, but...
-to the hell with it.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
That is so rude.
I mean, Fox and Friends
worked hard on that.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
"Boring!"
"Who needs policy experts
to pull information out of
when I have an ass?"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
(SCATTERED APPLAUSE)
Oh, but that's just--
That's just when
the fun started,
when he threw the paper
in the air,
because then he was free
to riff, unfettered!
So he started to go over
his greatest hits.
Did you see this?
Talking again about
how millions...
voted illegally in 2016.
That's right, Donald.
If it weren't for fraud,
you'd have won California.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
You're as popular out here as
bumper-to-bumper traffic
caused by a mudslide
caused by fracking.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
But you would have
won California.
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
And then, my favorite...
he said his polling is almost
at 60 percent,
his approval rating.
Sixty percent?
This is what he said, quote,
he said,
"A poll just came out
from Rasmussen,"
that's a conservative group,
but okay,
"A poll came out from
Rasmussen.
It's now 51, they say.
But it's 51, but you gotta add
seven or eight to that."
You know, like you do
with your penis.